joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
pleased to have back here after some
remarkable work in the past few weeks
for the Washington Post formerly if
Sports Illustrated and more Robert Clem
Co back here how are you Robert I'm
doing great how are you I'm doing well
before we get in to what you've been up
to the last few weeks I know you were on
top of the Dalvin cook story coming into
the draft and now here's Dalvin cook
saying in the last 24 hours
or at least a source telling Adam
Schefter that his contract needs to be
made more in line of what Christian
McCaffrey has or he's holding out and
part of the reason why he's so underpaid
with one year left on a contract is
because he wasn't drafted where his
talents should have had him drafted
Robert and I want to give you this stage
on his story yeah you know he's got a
fascinating one but it really it's not
that uncommon across the NFL you know he
comes from the worst neighborhoods in
the Miami area had a number of run-ins
with the law obviously had the big
injury early on in his career and I
think he's part of a generation of guys
that look at some of these running back
holdouts over the past few years and say
you know I need to get my money now and
I think he's in an especially good spot
just because that team and that offense
is so reliant on him but going back to
kind of his personal story there were a
lot of questions about how he would
handle life in the NFL how he would
handle that first big check and from
everything you hear out of Minnesota and
you know some teammates their ex
teammates he's been a model citizen in
the NFL and a guy that you know you feel
comfortable building a locker out a
locker room around so he's a great
success story
he really is we've had him on and we had
him on pre-draft we had him on as a
rookie and then we had him on last year
when he was a breakout star in this
league his problem is just he can't stay
healthy kid can not stay healthy he's
busy
the essential issue Robert yeah and and
you know that's why how can you blame
them for wanting to get paid right now
you know it you know parents don't don't
raise your kids to be running backs
right yes and then make sure they get
paid before they're 30 unless their name
is Frank Gore then they'll keep going on
and on and on like like like nobody's
business but you know you're right it's
a it's a story so was Dalvin wronged by
his draft status do you think Robert I
don't know I I don't think he
interviewed very well I don't think that
people felt like he had a great support
system around him and he could be a
long-term success in the NFL but you
know how many guys do you read about
every year where X number of teams
underestimate a guy's heart a guy's
desire to be great
his ability to you know power through
some of the adversary' adversity you
know I was talking with a GM yesterday
about a lot of the issues that we're
talking about now and in terms of racial
inequality and he was saying you know
the stories that I go back home and tell
my wife about these kids that I need
they're not about guys that you know had
a head start in the 400-meter race came
from great neighborhood came from great
families and you know are at this stage
now they're the stories about the guys
that didn't have a head start that had
all these obstacles and all this
adversity to overcome and so much of
that so much of what we encounter with
those kids is due to no fault of their
own it's about some of the symptoms of
racial inequality in the United States
and I think Dalvin cook story is you
dive deeper into it you know falls into
that category
Robert climb Co the Washington Post here
on the Rich Eisen show you just came
back how long were you in the city of
Minneapolis Robert I was there for eight
days eight days my word I guess I could
go macro here say what you see I mean I
know what you wrote about but for those
that may not know what did you see
Robert you know I got there Thursday
night
and that was the night that they set
fire to the third Precinct police
station and so that was kind of my first
impression you know this really wild
group of mostly teens you know very
mixed crowd in terms of racial
background a lot of women out there
surprisingly as well just a really
diverse group mmm
just laying waste to this several square
block area of the city and then you wake
up the next morning and you start
attending some of these protests and
some of these rallies and these memorial
for Floyd and I think you begin to
realize and you know I'm a newbie at
covering this sort of thing but you
begin to realize that everything that
you're seeing on CNN and on Fox a lot of
the things that you're seeing on
television are the highlight reel from
the night before but you know the stuff
that's happening during the day the
really positive conversation the people
cleaning up that's not really what makes
for good TV so you know once I got was
there for a couple days and got the feel
of it I tried to focus some of my
attention on kind of balancing that out
and telling the stories of the people
who were activists who were trying to
make a difference one of them actually
you know kind of intersected with sports
for me was Roy white the former NBA
first-round pick who you know played all
of a few minutes in the NBA and he's
become you know a protest activism
leader out in Minneapolis tell me more
about his story I read your piece and I
thought it was really interesting
obviously uh haven't you wanna hear - no
it was excellent how did you come across
him let's unpack his story a little bit
here for the listeners and viewers here
Robert yeah well you know the situation
is so chaotic there on the ground the
you know you there's a million stories
so it just kinda have to go outside and
start talking to people and right by our
hotel we were staying at the Residence
Inn you know the three post reporters
that were there was this enormous March
and then so I started walking in it and
talking to people and finding out how it
started and it turns out that Royce
White and a group of 30 Minnesota
current and former
basketball players football players
college pro what-have-you they started a
group text last summer about getting
together and finding a gym to workout
and so that they've kept that group text
going and then when this video came out
of George Floyd after he was killed
Royce White said to the group you know
those of us that have a prominent voice
in this community we need their we need
to do something and Royce has been an
advocate for mental health in sports and
in education for a long time ever since
he was drafted into the NBA and was
unable to fly because he has this
generalized anxiety disorder and there
was some hope that he could overcome it
but he never really did he spent a lot
of time bouncing around the
developmental leagues and actually
played up in Canada riding by bus won
the Canadian MVP at one year and then
was runner up the next year and then
semi-retired and got into the big three
last year but just hasn't gotten over
this fear of flying and so he's been in
Minneapolis work in the community about
on Midland and then this is his first
time on the frontlines of a protest and
he starts this group of 200 people at US
Bank Stadium where the Vikings play and
starts walking and they end up with
several thousand marching down i-35 west
across the Mississippi and they all take
a knee and then he addresses the crowd
and talks about how you know that they
don't want to show us non-violently
protesting like this so so we have to
you know try to bring as much attention
to as we can but what he talked about in
terms of the visceral reaction of that
video and being on the front lines of
approaches for the first time was
something I heard over and over in
Minneapolis I think a lot of people who
were on the fence or on the sidelines
before but sympathized with this sort of
activism have been brought out of the
shadows just by the visceral nature of
that killing and you could for somebody
who's covered the NFL for as long as you
have
would you say the last week in the NFL
from obviously the reaction of players
to the last two weeks then the murder of
George Floyd and the murderers of
Brianna Taylor and a Madhuri just to
name
three individuals whose demises have
shocked so many do you think from from
that to the commissioners video that
came in response to a player's video
that was sparked by an NFL employee
reaching out to the players to say hey
we want to do something on the heels of
what happened with Drew Brees that there
has been a change with the NFL can you
say that right now Robert I think there
has and you know time will tell how they
handle the activism that's going to
happen this season and what kind of
limits they try to put on player speech
certainly there'll be a change from what
they've done in the past in terms of
discouraging protesting during the
anthem but I think there has been a
change you know Roger Goodell represents
the owners and he's not going to make a
video like that without a handful of
influential owners agreeing that this
situation has reached a sort of critical
mass and you can't have that without the
violence across the city you can't cross
the country you can't have that without
the protests all across the country and
you can't have it without video right I
mean I mean I think the thing that's not
really talked about in all of this is
that all of these sorts of killings have
been happening since there have been
black people in the United States but
now it's become this reflex to record
everything and so moderates people who
were on the fence there I think they're
more swayed by the images of this stuff
then they were ever before and so I
think a group of owners had to have
realized that this has reached critical
mass and Roger Goodell doesn't do
anything without conferencing with with
those powerful owners and he came out
and made us
now you can criticize the statement and
say you know we should have mentioned
Colin Kaepernick and talked about you
know how Kaepernick's protest looks so
much more reasonable in hindsight he
didn't do that and so I think he's
always going to kind of told the line to
try to appease the more conservative
owners but what he said I think
represents the beginning of a new era in
the NFL where you're going to have
players that are so much more vocal
about their activism and the causes that
that matter to them than they ever work
for well I mean he said the words black
lives matter Robert which is you know
new and also you know he didn't say
Kaepernick's name specifically but him
saying we should have listened years ago
that's what else would he be referring
to other than Colin Kent right right so
right right you know and then so the
question is about Kaepernick here's what
Carlos Hyde said on Monday former
teammate of Colin Kaepernick's fresh off
his first career 1,000 yard seasons so
Hyde's career on the football field is
definitely something that's a trending
upward and he had this to say about the
situation I think started by sonic at
back I think based on cat-back data
that'll show that they were really
trying to move in a different direction
because Kath was making a statement four
years ago about what's going on today's
world and they naturally didn't bother
to listen to him there so I think they
should start by doing that do you think
that that would be an actual true signal
or do you think Kaepernick wouldn't want
to be part of something like that
because it might just be a box checked
by the NFL how do you take a statement
like that Robert clunk oh yeah you know
I think you do have to consider the role
tap Anik wants to play
at this point there is you know there is
so much pressure on the league and I'm
sure you know for years that there have
been elements of NFL ownership that have
said to you know certain owners certain
general managers if you guys can make
this happen it takes a lot of political
pressure off of us
but Kaepernick may not want to go into a
situation where he's not actually
competing for a starting job or he's not
actually needed if it feels like it's
just being done to satisfy the you know
the tides of public opinion that are
swaying so rapidly right now the big
mystery with Kaepernick is what he wants
because he doesn't speak in the media
that often he's not the vocal leader
that I think a lot of people that are on
his side want him to be he is has become
a symbol in a lot of ways I mean when
was the last time you heard Collin
address any of these issues of his
unemployment in public in an interview I
mean it
I think his camp has always been on the
stay of the stance that you know we
don't want to put it out in the media
and have the media manipulate our works
right but there are so many avenues now
for expression if you're an athlete that
is unmitigated by anybody else's voice
and I think you know in the next several
months or his opportunity to I you know
set the record straight and press the
NFL on this idea that he continues to be
blackballed based on his political
stance well I guess you know Robert
Klemke the Washington Post we got to
just linger on this issue for a second
here you know I guess the last time we
heard Kaepernick say something on the
subject was after the debacle there's no
other way to describe what happened in
the state of Georgia was at last
November for the tryout that was you
know slam together is the only way to
put it and then you know with an odd
very odd timing on when it happened why
it happened whenever really was any
description as to why it happened
and then the mistrust the distrust that
that sparked a change of venue at the
last second debacle from start to finish
is the only way to describe that that's
kind of the last time and by the way if
he wants to you know speak publicly and
not have his his words taken other than
what's coming out of his mouth he could
come on a live radio and television show
like this one and just and just have the
floor I'll say that once again so right
I mean that what the hell happened last
November and can that genie be put back
into the bottle and uncorked and start
again do you think yeah you know I think
there were several miscommunications and
they will sever there were several of
his terms that weren't met when it was
first talked about you know him having
this try out in Georgia at the Falcons
complex and I think the main one was
that he wanted the media there to
document it because you know if I were
Colin I wouldn't want all of these teams
to then come away from that tryout and
have these anonymous Scouts say yeah he
really just didn't have the zip on his
fastball anymore right because that's I
think that's the easy way out for a lot
of these teams but you know from the
team perspective there's really no
precedent for letting media come watch a
mass free agent tryout right but I think
the mistake for players is to focus on
whether or not Colin comes back as some
sort of marker for a measure of you know
the NFL's acceptance I mean there's so
many other things that the NFL can do
that can advance the the fight against
racial inequality I mean first and
foremost finally figure out a way to
have african-american coaches in
leadership positions and head coaching
positions and african-american general
managers because there are so many
people that are in that pipeline who
aren't getting the same opportunities as
you know this good old boys network
where you're seeing coaches sons and
relatives of coaches and son in laws of
coaches hire prominent coaching
positions all over the
and a lot of african-american coaches
who have you know put in more time and
had more success being skipped over so I
you know I think that's the first thing
the NFL can do and the other place where
you know nobody in the NFL in the
leadership has stepped up is in this
discussion of compensating
student-athletes in the NCAA because
right now the NFL is a beneficiary of a
system that some argue Rob's a lot of
African American teenagers coming out of
poverty of their earning power in the
athletic prime of their careers and you
haven't heard anybody in the NFL in a
leadership position talk about the
equity of that or the fairness of that
and it's because the NFL benefits from
that pipeline last one for you Robert
you again have been right at the middle
of this story covering it for the many
for Sports Illustrated Washington Post
so on and so forth USA Today right
you've been at the fort you talked to
NFL management you spoken to players you
know you even said that there's gonna be
a burst of activism that's coming this
fall we know it we all know it the NBA
will probably you know knock on wood go
first because they they will open up and
tip-off in July
I mean it's entirely possible baseball
does but that that will see a burst of
activism for the NFL this fall
how would you counsel if they said hey
Robert Clem co you've spoken everybody
here I put in your plate how would you
counsel everybody to figure out what to
do Robert yeah yeah it's a good question
and it's a story I'm actually working on
right now but I I mentioned I spoke to a
general manager yesterday and he talked
about what he's done over the last three
weeks and you know he took the phrase
black lives matter very literally and he
called all of the black men and women
that have mattered to him in his career
and in his life and called to check in
and see how they were doing
and also wanted to know what he could be
doing differently and some of those
people were in his organization some
were not and I think one of the
takeaways that he came away with is that
we need to sit down with players who may
not be in leadership positions you know
who may not be one of our captains but
these guys that have these real-life
tangible experiences with you know
police brutality with you know racial
profiling and talk to them about a plan
because if it doesn't feel like
everybody in our organization is
included in this discussion then we're
never going to achieve any degree of
solidarity on this thing and I think
when you know when Ferguson and
Baltimore were happening a lot of the
discussions that happen with teams were
around you know we're between coaches
and management and player leadership and
didn't involve every voice in the room
and I think if you know if I were giving
broad advice I would you know I would
tell these coaches these general
managers these owners to try to make
sure that everybody in the room feels
heard yeah but you know don't you think
that there needs to be a league wide
policy here that you know that team a
says some stand some kneel I mean we're
gonna have we're gonna run through the
same questions that we did in 2016 and
2017 now Robert I mean it's coming we
know it it's absolutely it's here
already you know drew brees had to
address the president himself on Twitter
to say don't make this a wedge issue so
we know it's coming the question is
though is you can't have team a say some
stand some some kneel and team B's like
those who don't want to stand stay in
the locker room and team C is like
everybody standing every side of the
locker room and everybody standing like
you you know like we can't have a repeat
so the question is can can there be on
on ownership side some new committee
that's formed as a listening committee I
don't know what you call it
you know player relation committee
and and then have a player's group of
players sit down with these owners and
come out with it and then this is what
we're gonna do is a league and Roger
comes out and says in a video this is
what we're doing and everybody goes in
plays football you know and yeah amongst
a pandemic on top of all of it but you
know what I'm saying like don't you
think that's what has to happen you know
I don't think that the NFL will want to
go out there and say you know we're
gonna put together a committee and
create a rule and say that players have
to stay in the locker room or players
can protest you know I think that they
will say we're gonna have the national
anthem before games we're gonna have the
players and coaches out there you know
if you want to protest you can and I
think that the network's will in turn
say this is still a hot-button issue for
us and we're just not going to show the
national anthem anymore and that will be
the establishment attempt to you know
quiet some of the criticism of what goes
on during the national anthem while
still trying to appease the players that
are protesting I think that's the middle
ground that they will ultimately reach
all right last one for you I lied I'm
assuming since you said you spent eight
days in Minneapolis you were at the
George Floyd Memorial are there several
Vikings there I don't know
Timberwolves arrived or if anybody else
professionally athletic athleisure you
were there yeah yeah you know I didn't
meet her interview any athletes there in
my time but I did read it several it's
not by you know I think that there was
sort of a happier vibe you know not so
much the activism the protesting that
you'd see in the marches across the city
in the in the protest outside of the
police precinct or you know different
media companies it it was more of you
know this is a real this is a healing
space and anybody that wants to come and
celebrate George's life please do that
and the one thing I noticed that really
stood out to me and I wrote a little
but about it a story that came out today
is all of these families they came out
to the memorial you know people with
kids five six you know up up through
teenagers and it occurred to me that you
know my education on dealing with the
police on racial inequity on police
brutality happened in learning about
Rodney King when I was a teenager and
and dealing with police you know later
on in life and reading about a lot of
these things later on at life whereas if
you're ten years old right now and you
have Twitter there's a good chance
you've seen the video of Floyd getting
choked to death so this generation is
dealing with all of these issues faster
than my generation did and all of these
parents I think that brought their kids
to the memorial are grappling with these
really difficult conversations about
racial inequity and it's it's happening
sooner and that was something that kind
of gave me hope really because if these
kids are talking about it and learning
about it sooner than you know it stands
the reason that their understanding of
it is going to be greater than ours was
at a younger age Robert thanks for the
time
again great work from you in the
Washington Post and and let's stay in
touch
I'd love to keep having this
conversation with you here on the show
thank you I appreciate it you got it
Robert Clem Cole at Robert Clem co KL e
mko on Twitter follow his work it really
is remarkable